le poing levé
la trentaine de supporters de julian
assange exulte devant la cour criminelle
dolbec
nous avons gagné s'exclament les
partisans du cofondateur de wikileaks
alors que la justice britannique qui
vient de refuser son extradition vers
les etats-unis malgré cette décision
favorable ses plus proches se veulent
prudents pour la suite
on ne peut pas célébrer nous célébrerons
le jour il rentrera à la maison je
demande au président des états unis d'y
mettre fin maintenant monsieur le
président démolissez les murs de cette
prison que nos petits garçons et leur
père libérer julian libérer la presse
libérez nous tous quel moment
c'est une lueur d'espoir pour commencer
la nouvelle année et j'espère une
nouvelle ère c'est un jour de victoire
pour y jouer un assange mais il faut
être prudent
ce n'est pas forcément une victoire pour
le journalisme pour justifier sa
décision la justice britannique met en
avant sa santé mentale instable une
possibilité souligné par l' expertise
psychiatrique selon la cour criminelle
les critères légaux nécessaires à
l'extradition ne sont donc pas remplies
cette décision de la justice britannique
nommé pourtant pas en terme à la saga
judiciaire
le département américain de la justice
s'est dit extrêmement déçu et annonce
son intention de faire appel
pour l'avocat français de julian assange
son client est persécuté par les états
unis
l'enjeu de ce dossier n'est pas
juridique l'enjeu de ce dossier les
politiques il faut comprendre que
c'étaient les états unis qui demandent
la persécution d'assange et il est
peut-être temps grâce à cette décision
que tous les autres pays du monde
défendre quelqu'un qui aujourd'hui
persécutés parce qu'ils ajustent
diffuser des informations personne
qu'ils soient américains pas américain
protégé par l'amendement numéro 1 ou pas
de la constitution des états unis ne
devraient être persécutés parce qu'ils
diffusent des informations
pourquoi parce que le droit à
l'information est un aux droits
démocratiques les plus précieux
l'australien risque donc toujours 175
ans de prison sur le sol américain
il est accusé d'avoir diffusé plus de
700 mille documents classés secret
relatif aux activités militaires et
diplomatiques américaines notamment en
irak et en afghanistan pour échapper à
son extradition julian assange s'est
réfugiée pendant près de sept ans
derrière les murs de l'ambassade
équateur à londres mais il en a
finalement été expulsé en avril 2019 et
ensuite été arrêté depuis lors ses
soutiens à travers le monde réclame et
sa grâce auprès du président américain
une requête toujours refusé en attendant
le cofondateur de wikileaks pourrait
retrouver une liberté provisoire
la justice britannique se prononcera ce
mercredi lors d'une nouvelle audience